3 Middle one more time It's okay to start from the
beginning It's okay
to expect something from me, but I'm just disappointed.
Cut
off the line that came in What are you thinking about?
Mitsuru-kun
, you can rely on more people.
I believe in Mitsuru-kun,
so Mitsuru-kun also wants to believe in me.
I can
promise you
hiro I've done my best I've become stronger I'll
fight with
hiro I've kept my promise with hiro A wide poomen promise with hiro I
'm just betrayed by believing in others
I wanted something, I was stupid I was
afraid I had a promise
[Music]
[Applause]
String-kun was deeply hurt. It's so deep that I
can't really recover
[Music
] masa
I was  You'll betray the fall and hurt you badly.
Breaking your promise I
'm not the kind and nice child that everyone says, so
if I'm badly betrayed by someone,
I'll blame or complain about it.  I feel like I can't do it
[Music]
So forgive me,
that's what Mitsuru-kun decides, I mean
,
that's what happens in us,
we're perfect for adults  Because I don't have
ani
I'm involved with people I
don't laugh or cry with
everyone I believe in Mitsuru-kun